[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
les parfumeurs le savent bien perdre son
odorat ce n'est pas anodin ne plus
sentir un plat qui mijote ni le goût
d'un bon vin ni l'odeur de ses proches
les conséquences sur la qualité de vie
sont considérables pourtant ce trouble
était sous-estimé
en fait il faut il faut le perdre pour
se rendre compte à quel point on a eu la
chance jusqu'à présent de pouvoir
respirer toutes les odeurs du monde sans
cesse avec l'épidémie de covid-19 tout a
changé la perte de l'odorat est l'un des
symptômes les plus fréquents de la
maladie elle touche plus de 70% des
personnes infectées alors face à
l'explosion des cas chercheur et
médecins organisent la prise en charge
c'est incroyable à quel point les choses
vont vite désormais parce que on donne
une priorité à un problème mondial
pourquoi l'odorat est-il insensible
comment le retrouver c'est le thème de
ce nouveau numéro d'état de santé
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro d'état de santé on va
s'intéresser à un mot qu'on a découvert
à l'occasion de la pandémie c'est
l'anosmie c'est la perte de l'odorat et
ça a touché en tout 5 millions de
personnes c'est considérable et
l'anosmie et bien depuis on s'y
intéresse de très près on découvre que
c'est une pathologie passionnante et que
ce sens l'odorat est plein de ressources
et les mêmes un peu mystérieux bonjour
arthurden merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous vous êtes un spécialiste des
troubles de l'odeur à vous nous direz
tout à l'heure pourquoi d'ailleurs un
jour vous êtes intéressé à ce sens mais
alors je voudrais tout de suite vous
poser une question parce que ça dira
sans doute tu auras des résonances chez
ceux qui ne nous écoutent chez nos
proches qui ont perdu le goût pendant la
pandémie et bien il y en a beaucoup qui
s'appliquait à mettre des odeurs sous
leur nez pour récupérer le goût
confusion la confusion est même
sémantique puisque quand on parle de
goût en fait on parle de tout cela alors
que le goût sur la langue c'est ce qu'on
appelle la gustation donc les cinq
saveurs par exemple on déguste un repas
salé sucré on va reconnaître des saveurs
amères acides et puis aussi le umami qui
est le glutamate dans les sauces
asiatiques ça c'est les saveurs c'est il
y a 5 saveurs seulement mais imaginons
qu'on mange une soupe avec une couleur
orange et que bah on est dit que cette
soupe elle est salée comment déterminer
s'il y a de la carotte dedans de la
tomate du navet du potiron ça c'est le
nez qui va faire ce travail d'où la
confusion entre le goût et l'odorat et
en fait les deux travaillent en même
temps et déterminent en fait des
paramètres très très importants pour
notre alimentation par exemple et si
j'ai le nez bouché en hiver parce que
j'ai un petit coup de froid et que j'ai
beaucoup de mucus qui me coule dans le
nez j'ai plus donc d'odorat je suis
incapable de dire s'il y a du poireau
dans la soupe que je suis en train de
manger par contre je peux dire si c'est
salé ou pas alors vous me direz comment
on perd l'odorat etc mais une fois qu'on
l'a perdu sur les conséquences et pour
donner la mesure de l'importance de ce
sens
j'ai cru comprendre qu'on pouvait même
faire des dépressions parce qu'on
n'avait plus
pourquoi parce qu'on commence par cette
information olfactive que l'on sent dans
notre nez mais ensuite derrière il y a
tout le traitement cérébral et dans ce
traitement cérébral les informations
olfactives vont engendrer en fait de
multiples émotions extrêmement
puissantes et aussi des mémoires et
c'est ce qu'on appelle aussi les
madeleines de Proust quand on fait appel
à Marcel Proust qui mange sa madeleine
une fois qu'il est adulte il va se
souvenir de son enfance avec des
émotions et des mémoires extrêmement
puissantes donc imaginez une personne
anosmique qui a perdu cette capacité de
reconnaissance des odeurs forcément il y
a moins d'émotions moins de plaisir et
potentiellement un danger de dépression
alors comment on peut perdre de rein on
va avoir ça juste après mais on va
d'abord voir votre portrait
[Musique]
rage gurden et directeur de recherche en
neurosciences au CNRS c'est un
spécialiste de l'olfaction il travaille
au sein du laboratoire de biologie
fonctionnelle et adaptative sur la
représentation des odeurs par le cerveau
et les interactions entre la prise
alimentaire et l'olfaction
afin de venir en aide aux personnes
anosmiques avec l'association
anosmie.org il a mis au point un
protocole de rééducation olfactive il a
été téléchargé des dizaines de milliers
de fois avec l'épidémie de covid-19
[Musique]
donc comme avec le covid dont on parlera
avec la perte olfactive qu'on peut
compenser par un programme de
rééducation olfactive c'est à dire
s'entraîner à sentir des odeurs
différentes tous les jours on peut faire
exactement la même chose avec le
vieillissement ça va nous aider en fait
à réactiver notre nez le capteurs nous
détecteurs on n'est pas aussi ça des
récepteurs olfactifs tout au fond de
notre nez et ça ça va nous faire
beaucoup de bien
du Sudoku il faut faire il faut faire ça
avec les huiles essentielles bon donc on
le perd au fil de l'existence et sinon
est-ce qu'on peut naître sans odorat
alors malheureusement oui c'est ce qu'on
appelle un peu dans le terme biomédical
des anneaux SMIC congénitaux c'est à
dire que de façon génétique en fait on
va pas avoir ces détecteurs donc j'ai
parlé qui sont fonctionnels c'est-à-dire
ils ne marchent pas c'est quelques
dizaines et centaines de milliers de
personnes sont en souffrance parce que
comme tous les anosmiques elles peuvent
avoir un problème d'intoxication
alimentaire c'est à dire par exemple ne
pas reconnaître le lait avarié souvent
on fait ça on prend on sent et on sait
que c'est à varié bah là on a pas cette
capacité ou alors sentir le brûlé dans
la cuisine ou le gaz on peut plus le
faire ils sont absolument handicap
majeur cela dit elles l'ont pas eu la
perte non parce que c'est ce qu'on voit
c'est la grosse différence c'est cette
émotion en fait exacerbée de la perte de
l'odorat chez les personnes covid par
exemple du jour au lendemain mais aussi
chez des personnes qui ont eu des
accidents donc des chocs craignent qui
qui vont purement physiologique il peut
y avoir le nerf parce que c'est un nerf
oui tout à fait
et ce nerf là il peut être sectionné et
si jamais il est sélectionné on devient
anosmique à cause d'un trauma crânien
par exemple et la catastrophe c'est on
retrouve ce que l'on a vu avec le covid
c'est-à-dire du jour au lendemain en
perle l'odorat et alors là la qualité de
la vie s'en ressent alors comment le
virus a touché l'odorat regardez cette
infographie
[Musique]
lui c'est Marcel Marcel adore les
madeleines leur odeur suave leur saveur
sucrée et citronnée mais depuis qu'il a
eu le covid-19 Marcel ne sent plus rien
pourtant il n'a pas le nez bouché alors
que se passe-t-il dans les narines de
Marseille regardez ici la fente
olfactive est enflée et bloquée c'est
cette partie du nez qui est responsable
de la perception des odeurs en effet
dans cette zone appelée épithélium
olfactif se trouve habituellement les
cils qui permettent la détection des
molécules odorantes par les neurones
sensoriels mais ceux de Marcel ont
disparu pas étonnant qu'il ne semble
plus rien certaines cellules de
l'épithélium ont été infectées par le
virus ainsi que des neurones olfactifs
mais comment le Sark of 2 s'est-il frayé
un chemin jusqu'ici
d'après une étude de l'inrae ce sont les
cellules de soutien qui servent de porte
d'entrée au virus elles sont les seules
à exprimer les récepteurs nécessaires au
sarskov2 pour pénétrer dans les cellules
la réponse immunitaire à l'infection
prend la forme d'une inflammation qui
peut elle aussi causer des dégâts dans
l'épithélium olfactif Marcel mettra
d'autant plus de temps pour recouvrer
son odorat qu'il en faudra
l'inflammation pour se résorber et aux
cellules pour se régénérer
[Musique]
alors on voit comment le virus attaque
l'odorat et quand on a un covid long qui
s'accompagne d'une anosmie longue c'est
très perturbant c'est extrêmement
perturbant parce que ça revient à tous
les problèmes dont on a dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure des accidents qui peuvent
arriver des dépressions qui peuvent se
développer une insécurité sociale
imaginez même que je ne me sens plus
c'est-à-dire je me sens pas là sur ce
plateau si je sens une mal assure par
exemple donc du coup c'est très très
perturbant pour quelqu'un de pas se
sentir
facile depuis qu'on a commencé cette
émission c'est que vous nous parlez de
choses qui existent depuis longtemps
mettez totalement sous-traitée mais
complètement sous traitée c'est français
qu'il n'y aurait cette pathologie à ce
point ou bah en tout cas c'est un
paradoxe français au pays de la
parfumerie de l’œnologie de la
gastronomie avec tout ce qu'on voit en
plus à la télé comme émission c'est très
très paradoxal de pas avoir un intérêt
de la population pour ce sens là et
c'est étonnant parce que par exemple en
Allemagne ou en Angleterre il y a des
centres de d'étude de l'olfaction qui
sont plus avancées alors on a un peu
rattrapé le retard avec le covid mais
voilà c'était un paradoxe français qui
s'efface un petit peu maintenant oui et
puis on a quand même voulu avec Marianne
Cazeau journaliste d'état de santé
comprendre pourquoi c'était considéré un
peu comme secondaire ou en tout cas bon
pas finalement pas un handicap reportage
à Lyon signé Marianne Cazaux
[Musique]
renoncer à son odorat plutôt qu'à son
téléphone portable voilà ce que plus de
la moitié des jeunes Américains
affirmaient préféré dans cette étude de
2011 ce sont ces souvent perçu comme
subalterne c'est aussi ce que penserait
jusqu'à ce qu'elle attrape le covid-19
il y a un an lait de coco gingembre de
ce plat qui mijote Aurélia ne sent rien
ni l'odeur à Larmande du gaz ni même
celle de son fils quand elle l'embrasse
Aurélia espère retrouver peu à peu les
plaisirs de l'odorat elle a pris
conscience de la valeur de ce sens
en fait il faut il faut le perdre pour
se rendre compte à quel point on a eu la
chance jusqu'à présent de pouvoir
respirer toutes les odeurs du monde sans
cesse la vie a quand même moins de
saveurs moins de goût moins de saveurs
l'odeur des proches est un manque énorme
et puis après c'est de se rendre compte
à quel point on croise toute la journée
des odeurs quand il y a plus du tout
tout ça il y a un côté où on est
extrêmement en fait isolé
la sensation d'être vraiment dans une
bulle mais alors pourquoi l'odorat
est-il sous-estimé l'un des responsables
c'est lui Paul Broca au 19e siècle ce
spécialiste de l'anatomie du cerveau à
comparer les bulbes olfactifs humains à
ceux des différentes espèces résultat il
nous a classé dans la catégorie des
annoncesmatiques animaux dont le faction
est peu développé et voilà comment il
expliquait
l'homme trouve dans ses autres sens et
dans son intelligence des ressources qui
diminuent notablement l'utilité de
l'odorat mais c'était une erreur il faut
dire que Paul Broca ne disposait pas des
outils de ce centre de recherche
lyonnais donc vous allez être installé
dans ce scanner IRM qui permet de
mesurer l'activité de votre cerveau
pendant cet IRM cette volontaire devra
sentir des fragrances et indiquer si
elle les trouve agréables ou non
l'équipe de Mustapha Ben Safi a mené
cette expérience sur 30 personnes
et voilà ce qu'il se passe dans notre
cerveau lorsque nous sentons une odeur
déplaisante
nos femmes bulbes olfactifs se trouvent
dans cette zone en couleur mais elle
n'est pas la seule à être activée la
perception olfactive c'est pas qu'une
histoire de de région olfactive ça va
bien au-delà l'odeur elle recrute les
régions du système émotionnel voir les
régions du système de la mémoire ou des
mémoires et également de temps en temps
on a besoin de se représenter l'odeur
avec d'autres formes sensorielles comme
ici avec le cortex de la vision
sentir stimule donc bien plus que notre
simple de rat plus méconnu encore les
odeurs peuvent même nous permettre de
communiquer nos émotions exemple avec ce
jeune cobaye qui regarde des vidéos
humoristiques
[Rires]
les odeurs corporelles émissent pendant
cette activité agréable son collectées
sur son t-shirt préparer et diffuser à
travers ses tubes jusque dans le nez de
cet autre participante elle ne sait pas
à quoi elle correspondent mais voici les
réactions observées
on voit un bon pic ici du du muscle
zygomatique a priori ça c'est plutôt une
odeur qui a été plaisante pour la
personne
l'expérience montre qu'une forme de
contagion des émotions a lieu à travers
les odeurs corporelles mais le plus
intéressant pour Stephen Richard c'est
que tout cela se fait sans qu'on s'en
rende compte quand on demande aux
personnes qu'est-ce qu'elles sentent ou
est-ce qu'elle est dans un petit quelque
chose c'est par cela nous disent
qu'elles ont rien senti et pourtant il y
a quand même un effet derrière c'est le
sens qui est en fin de compte est le
plus mystérieux c'est quelque chose qui
agit
de manière non consciente sur beaucoup
de nos comportements on n'est pas
forcément conscient de de ce que vous
avez sur nous voilà pourquoi Aurélia ne
s'attendait pas à voir son quotidien
changé autant en perdant l'odorat mais à
l'avenir ce sens sous-estimé sera
peut-être mieux compris grâce aux
chercheurs
[Musique]
on a aucune conscience de ce que ce sens
nous nous importe à quel point ce sens
nous importe et là on voyait dans le
reportage cette mère qui ne sent plus
son enfant voilà imaginez la tragédie
d'une maman qui ne peut plus sentir ses
enfants le reconnaître les bonnes odeurs
de ses enfants qu'elle connaît depuis
bébé donc et en plus et là cette vision
temporelle de du développement de son
enfant avec des odeurs qui sont
caractéristiques du développement de son
enfant et tout d'un coup il est privé de
ça du jour au lendemain donc c'est la
catastrophe absolue c'est c'est un drame
en fait est-ce qu'on a plus ou moins
d'odorat selon les individus à la
naissance l'aîné par exemple parler de
parfumerie tout à l'heure ce sont des
personnes qui ont un nez
particulièrement développé alors là
aussi problème sémantique on les appelle
des nez mais ils sont absolument pas des
nez dans le sens où ils auraient un nez
ils perdé c'est plutôt leur cerveau et
leur apprentissage de leur métier et
leur connaissance des différentes
molécules odorantes dans les parfums qui
font ça et ils vous le
pour les grandes marques de parfumerie
mais on peut avoir un nez très très
développé avec une connaissance en fait
fin des des vins des parfums etc et
c'est par l'entraînement et
l'apprentissage que les nez deviennent
nés je vais chez un médecin généraliste
je dis que j'ai perdu l'odeur et pas
rien faire pour moi ces ingénéralise
pure non il peut vous orienter vers un
ORL
et eux ils savent prendre en charge à
nos souvenirs
à la base mais comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure avant la pandémie en France la
prise en charge ORL était très très
faible et malheureusement il y avait
c'était ce qu'on appelle une errance
médicale dans le milieu de la santé
c'est à dire que les personnes allaient
de médecins aux médecins sans avoir de
solution et effectivement l'anosmie
était même pas très bien considéré dans
les milieux ORL donc du coup la pandémie
a aussi au fil du bien dans ce cadre là
c'est à dire dans la prise en charge des
malades exactement et on va voir dans
dans le reportage de Marianne Cazaux à
Nice maintenant que il y a même des
consultations qui ont été créées dédiés
à la nocemi ce qui était absolument
inenvisageable avant pour votre
spécialité quand même il y a un avant et
un après covid regardez le reportage
[Musique]
les troubles de l'odorat peuvent être
très déstabilisant
depuis 8 mois comme pour cette patiente
alors la prise en charge est urgente
[Musique]
depuis le début de l'épidémie ce médecin
voit les patients anosmiques défilés
dans sa consultation ORL celles-ci est
la 9e de la matinée ah ben on a été
carrément obligé de créer une
consultation dédiée aux troubles
olfactifs à laquelle nous participons ce
matin
puisque avant
c'était les pertolfactives complètes
comme ça c'était rarement plus de 10
patients par an et là vous voyez qu'on
dépasse largement les 10 patients par
semaine
pour organiser cette nouvelle prise en
charge il a fallu s'équiper en test the
factif et faire appel aux rares
praticiens qui s'intéressaient déjà à
l'odorat au CHU de Nice
bien confortablement cette spécialiste
en neurosciences est chargée de préciser
le diagnostic de l'ORL grâce à des tests
plus poussés de perception olfactive
comme celui-ci mais aussi de mémoire et
de langage
l'église au château à l'arrivée de
l'épidémie de covid-19 cela faisait déjà
trois ans qu'elle travaillait sur les
troubles de l'odorat dans son petit
bureau avec des kits faits maison comme
celui-ci à l'époque c'était un sujet qui
est intéressé peu la médecine c'est une
autre odeur
il y a quelques orthophonistes qui
l'utilisaient un petit peu il y a
quelques ORL qui travaillaient sur le
faction il y avait des laboratoires de
recherche aussi qui travaillaient sur le
faction mais globalement en France on se
comptait sur les doigts des deux mains
quoi c'était assez restreint on
travaillait sur un sujet qui était un
sujet très passionnant mais qui était un
sujet de niche
son expertise a permis de proposer
rapidement des solutions aux patients
souvent de la rééducation olfactive à
domicile
je recommande au docteur Vandersteen de
vous mettre sur un programme de
stimulation de LoL faction périphérique
cette méthode existait déjà avant
l'épidémie mais c'est avec des centaines
de consultations de suivi comme celle-ci
et autant de données qualitatives que
les médecins ont pu mesurer son
efficacité et ses faiblesses par rapport
à la au premier bilan que vous avez eu
avant la rééducation olfactive il y a un
bénéfice mais qui domine principalement
sur la perception des odeurs
sur le fait de différencier les odeurs
ou la fin c'était un petit peu plus
difficile
et l'identification des odeurs c'est un
pas tellement progressé
face à des résultats mitigés comme cela
il a fallu développer une nouvelle
méthode de rééducation olfactive mieux
adaptée au covid de long et cette
passion ne pourrait-on bénéficier
lorsque les se cliniques commencera un
projet rendu possible par le mécénat
d'un grand industriel du parfum c'est
incroyable à quel point les choses vont
vite désormais parce que on donne une
priorité à un problème mondial et donc
en libère des fonds on peut y voir un
bien dans dans l'horreur de la pandémie
c'est de pouvoir accéder plus facilement
à des voies de recherche à des voies de
traitement que quelque chose qui en
temps normal aurait intéressé que 5% de
la population et donc que 5% des
financeurs
la prise en charge de s'améliore donc
grâce à ce nouveau coup de projecteur et
elle se pérennise les praticiens se
forment comme cette stagiaire auprès de
Magali Pen un département spécialisé
dans l'olfaction va même voir le jour
ici au CHU de Nice voilà qui pourrait
profiter aux personnes à nos SMIC de
longue date pour ces patients la crise
du covid-19 pourrait aussi être synonyme
d'espoir
[Musique]
on mesure l'importance que l'odorat a
maintenant beaucoup plus
depuis la pandémie c'est vrai est-ce que
il pourrait y avoir du dépistage est-ce
qu'il y en a d'ailleurs alors dépistage
chez l'enfant par exemple ça n'existe
pas mais c'est tout à fait envisageable
parce que il y a des protocoles en fait
dans les cabinets ORL qui qui sont
développés que l'on pourrait adapter en
médecine générale ou en pédiatrie pour
quand l'enfant en fait à ces tests
visuels ou auditif et ben on pourrait
insérer en fait un test olfactif pour
pouvoir savoir si son odorat marche
normalement ou pas c'est assez simple à
faire oui c'est assez simple à faire et
je pense qu'il y a deux aspects qui
peuvent intéresser monsieur Véran notre
ministre de la Santé d'abord il est
neurologue donc je pense que ce qu'il y
a rapport avec les neurosciences et la
bonne santé de la qualité de la vie des
personnes au niveau cérébral et social
ça intéresse et deuxièmement de point de
vue simplement économique ça peut
intéresser toute la société parce que
avec une médecine de prévention on va
éviter tous les accidents dont on a
parlé depuis tout à l'heure et ça c'est
un gain économique pour la sécurité
sociale et les assurances qui sont qui
est pas négligeables
quand on a un trouble de l'humeur quand
on ne se sent pas bien qu'on est déprimé
etc est-ce que c'est intéressant est-ce
qu'il faudrait avoir le réflexe
d'interroger entre guillemets son odorat
oui ça s'appelle l'aromachologie c'est à
dire le fait en fait de se refaire du
bien émotionnellement par la stimulation
de certaines huiles essentielles qui
sont connues depuis très très longtemps
pour être bénéfique en fait et là aussi
ça a été plutôt tardivement qu'on a
étudié ça au niveau cérébral parce que
c'est on se disait c'est des recettes de
grand-mère certes efficaces mais sans
fondement scientifique et petit à petit
là on commence à comprendre ces recettes
de grand-mère comment elles agissent sur
le cerveau et peuvent effectivement
faire beaucoup de bien à des personnes
qui ont des troubles de l'humeur
qu'est-ce qui vous a pris vous occuper
de l'odeur je pose la question comme ça
souriant mais c'est rare un spécialiste
de l'odorat on voit à quel point c'est
important c'est précieux et vous comment
ça s'est passé je suis parti aux
États-Unis pour faire ce qu'on appelle
une période pose doctorale j'étais à New
York dans un laboratoire qui s'occupait
en fait de le faction et moi je venais
du domaine de la dopamine et du plaisir
et du coup je me suis dit est-ce qu'on
peut avoir un pont en fait entre
justement le faction et ses molécules et
ce plaisir et c'est là où j'ai commencé
en fait aux États-Unis et alors c'était
génial parce que j'étais dans une équipe
internationale avec japonais indien
allemand etc et on avait tous nos
préférences olfactive très très marqués
culturellement et c'est là où on voit
aussi la richesse de l'olfaction dans
chaque pays dans chaque continent avec
une culture et une société qui est bâtie
aussi autour de cette de ce sens
primordial
alors pour conclure vous votre rêve
c'est quoi c'est qu'on développe une
culture de olfaction ah oui c'est je
pense une nécessité absolue c'est c'est
un sens qui est tellement bénéfique pour
tellement de paramètres dans nos vies de
tous les jours que ce serait vraiment
dommage de passer à côté de ça pas très
cher qu'il y a des huiles essentielles
ça coûte pas très cher et donc ça
enrichit la vie en émotion en mémoire en
dialogue parce que dès qu'on sent une
odeur on a tendance à discuter en fait
ensemble donc du coup c'est aussi un
médiateur du lien social et du dialogue
social merci beaucoup parce que la
connexion que vous nous avez aidée à
faire entre l'odorat et l'émotion toutes
les émotions qui nous traversent vous
parler de la madeleine de Proust c'est
quand même universel et sans doute c'est
plus l'odeur qui l'inscrit ce souvenir
d'enfance dans sa mémoire que le
strictement le goût c'est passionnant
merci infiniment d'avoir été avec nous
dans cet état de santé on se retrouve
très vite pour un prochain numéro
[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance vous
a présenté état de santé
[Musique]